ces conservateurs et historien d'art
sont venus marcher sur les traces du
peintre gauguin en martinique
lens turin les mornes entre car b saint
pierre la lumière les couleurs qu'il a
peintes mais aussi nos archives les
photos d'époque tous les intéresse dans
ses recherches de centre
d'interprétation paul gauguin leur sert
naturellement de guide
car une grande exposition se prépare à
amsterdam sur les oeuvres martiniquaise
du peintre une première mondiale
depuis le voyage de goughin ici en 1887
on est très heureux de cette exposition
puisque pour la première fois tous les
tableaux presque tous les tableaux
martiniquais seront réunis ensemble et
nous ce serait une grande chance de
pouvoir aller les voir en vrai entre
guillemets sur place et d'avoir un
nouvel oeil dessus
van gogh était ami avec gauguin et
possédez de toile et plusieurs esquisses
de sa période martiniquaise celles ci
sont donc désormais exposé au musée van
gogh d'amsterdam qui veut réunir les
autres détenus par des collectionneurs
ou des musées du monde entier en
marchant à travers la campagne
ces oeuvres nommé au magot est au bord
de la rivière ont soudainement pris vie
j'ai contemplé 16h rostand deux fois ses
peintures finalement venir jusqu'ici
découvrir ces paysages certains presque
inchangé c'est incroyable lorsque
gauguin a commencé à peindre
ils faisaient de l'impressionnisme
peignait des paysages mais il a voulu se
distinguer des autres impressionniste
qu'il est s'est dit pourquoi ne pas
peindre des personnages vraiment lorsque
vous regardez ses toiles vous comprenez
que gauguin c'est vraiment trouver ici
en tant qu'artiste un pain des tropiques
c'est bien en martinique que la peinture
de goury 1 prend un tournant décisif qui
préfigure déjà ses futurs toile
polynésienne le centre d'interprétation
du québec ne possède certes aucun
original mais il sait raconter une
histoire avec lettre personnelle et
photographies d'époque
pour nous c'est une inspiration comment
faire comment
et notre exposition plus tard cette
année alors je pense que c'est vraiment
ça donne une belle idée c'est un peu le
retracer à travers les photographies
qu'on a trouvé dans les archives au
musée de l'histoire et l'ethnographie
c'est il ya des sources tellement riche
ici avec tout le monde et archives les
documentations les photos de cette
époque on peut vraiment comprendre un
peu un peu mieux tout le contexte social
les personnages les habitations des
plantations tout ça si vous passez par
amsterdam l'exposition des oeuvres
martiniquaise de gauguin sur un visible
du 5 octobre au 13 février prochain